[Music]
and just go to the dentist News lived an
old truck oh yeah sure insurance can you
auto insurance we get it no no I was
saying how the journal oh I think you
might read by I kicked the ice under the
fridge Steve a man almost died from
poking at popcorn stuck in his teeth Oh
what huh Wow gingivitis what the colonel
who did it get stuck in there and then
bacteria grew around it and then he okay
so this guy his name is Adam he's 41
years old father of three Oh No he
almost died what for a really corny
reason from the article this is kind of
[ __ ] you should never tell my wife
because now she's gonna get a piece of
corn stuck in her teeth and you think
she's gonna die luckily for you don't
really I don't need popcorn so okay know
what ended up happening here she's a
hypochondriac that's true so he was
sharing some popcorn with his wife while
they were watching a movie and that's
when he got a piece of like Colonel
stuck in the back of his like the left
side of that before
you gotta get yeah you ever tried to
pick out your tongue but then during the
movie theater you can hear a person
making a lot of noises I like it he
ended up getting it's stuck in there for
three days he used pieces are hughes
items found laying around like a pen cap
a toothpick a piece of wire and even a
nail what is he using floss bro yeah we
games of hepatitis or some [ __ ] so I'm
assuming he did the basics like
toothbrush enough dental floss probably
but they're mentioning this so he could
but he didn't go to the dentist so a
week later he started suffering night
sweats fatigue headaches and eventually
he was diagnosed with a heart murmur all
signs of an infection so he and
getting a potentially fatal blood
infection because of this Wow
what ended up happening is that he got
infected on his gums and because like
your gums are connected to your
bloodstream so then the infection spread
to the bloodstream which went to his
heart which ended up eating at his heart
valve like the infection was of like the
inner lining of his heart chamber what
Mihal and which ended up damaging his
heart so he ended up having to get open
heart surgery cash bacteria or that
infectious sorry happened because he was
poking out either cuz the kernel was
stuck in there because of the fact that
he was poking at it he was using a lot
of unsanitary things to get to it so he
got an infection disinfect it
squonk kernel opened up the gums and
then the bacteria from all that [ __ ]
went in yeah because he was taking
[ __ ] nails out of dog poop and
sticking it now see you I were excited
about dental insurance art women we are
okay cuz I nail up a lot of dog poop
okay so Adam he said that the doctor
said we're ready for this yeah that if
he didn't go to the park he would have
died he would have died in three I tell
you in three days I should go to the
doctor see because he said that most
people die when they are at a 350 on an
infection scale and he was at 340 okay
so he's not that much of a weak [ __ ]
the infection had eaten his heart valves
completely so what do they do they gotta
replace your hurt that was there yes she
ended up having to get open the whole
pipes got ruined man better at the first
sign of something new
or the doctor you listen to me ingrown
toenail both or at least wait till we
get life insurance yeah but guess what I
can take him out you just gotta wait to
get a heart murmurs that seems like to
be this this guy he wouldn't even carry
be like a snuff in I'll go if I gotta go
cuz I'm only cuz your grandpa you know
what else was a sign for this dude
though what okay so first he thought he
got a cold he's bleeding out his ears
not that far off
oh so first he got he got a quote he
thought you got a cold then he grew into
what he assumed was a flu so he went to
the doctor he diagnosed him with a mild
heart murmur sent him for blood tests
and x-rays both came back showing
nothing more than slightly raised
inflammation markers Wow good idea going
to the doctor well done so then he was
sent home with medication but then a few
days later he was still experiencing few
flu-like symptoms and he had also
developed a blood blister on his toe
which was later diagnosed as a Janeway
lesion which is an external indication
of an infective endocarditis
hard to be this guy is the kind of guy
that drives his car with a check engine
light on man what I would have done I'd
have been like hey yeah if you weren't
here she looks at me does Eve I'm gonna
say anything he's like please don't say
[ __ ] so he ended up just like juggling a
lot like trying to like get over this
that's what I do and he was just dealing
with intense leg pain because of that
lesion oh that's crazy finally he went
to the hospital and they that's when
they did this test and that's when they
found out that the muscle ache in his
leg turned out to be an infected blood
clot it was blocking his femoral artery
which required a five-hour operation to
clear the truth you wouldn't go to the
doctor if you just had a leg trip if you
just had a leg do you thought you just
I'll be told the truth about something
real quick if I go to the doctor the
first time doctor says you're fine you
got nothing wrong with you
I'm not going to doctor twice yeah most
people go like Oregon Jax go like 20
times
buying a life insurance immediately you
don't have life insurance now you should
get it on him we're going to you don't
need it it's on my desk
I'm fine I'm just on you not me oh [ __ ]
don't don't jinx me with life insurance
but if you're married you should get it
yeah it's a jinx Gio don't you know the
scam of life insurance
that's the only reason why is already on
my list of things to do [ __ ] scam Gio
to J's it's a jinx sir I had to get help
new health insurance first dental
insurance and now moving on a life
insurance right if I die [ __ ] it is a
single guy okay that's what I'm saying I
would take a screenshot of you doing
that and put it on a [ __ ] loving
memory forever and put on the back yeah
and we Photoshop a sunset in the back
exactly sunset always a census I leave
nothing behind but a video is full of
laughter and maybe some money in the
bank account there you go yeah even for
oh I'll give it to you guys if you want
all right thank you I mean I'm not gonna
use it one of your guns yeah sick okay
so bad scattergoods yeah whoa I mean I'm
building a brand-new 0di gun channel
back to Adam so he was treated with
medications to fight off the infection
but then once they did tests scans
that's when they revealed that his heart
had been severely damaged and would need
emergency surgery so that's when he was
transferred over to a different hospital
for a seven-hour open-heart surgery to
replace his his aortic valve and repair
his mitral valve and so luckily he made
a quick recovery and he returned home I
made some popcorn he said he will never
eat popcorn again I wouldn't either
never but it wasn't the pop it's his
troubleshooting I know I never go to the
doctor either
oh I can't believe you said I'll never
eat popcorn is Australian
let me that's gonna happen I knew it
shouldn't be the pump maybe it was that
nail like that you stuck in your [ __ ]
mouth okay okay it's gonna happen again
we're gonna talk about Adam just take it
easy and I'll see your mouth wall a nail
a pen cap he looks happy
oh [ __ ] you lost a lot of weight I
thought I had severe jetlag but I think
I was battling an infection cuz you
remember went to here was here he was
saying how like he had a lymph node that
swelled up and had burst it with us
saying that I didn't hear and then I had
three lymph nodes swell up and I looked
it up and it was like oh could be cancer
we're all growing in my armpit a bit
yeah did you call the doctor no I worked
out winter we're gonna get his money i
swelled up it bursts drop burst
yeah with pus oh yeah and then I went to
sleep you look like a pimp or what does
it look like it's oh it gets so you know
like your lymph nodes here right like
you know how they swell up when you're
sick it's like that but like on your arm
but what is it how does it exit out of
the skin like that well you do it's like
a fatty tumor is it a bone
have you ever gotten checked out are you
saying knows yourself diagnosed myself a
little there's still like some remnants
of it but I've got one that was kind of
groove what are your leg to what am I
like as well you should check the family
has this my brother has genetic yeah
so sue me it's not something no but it's
not anything well how do you know cuz
I'm fine I think he did my blood work
I'm fine
what you know how everyone was during
the brezza when I mean what yes I think
I was too but I didn't realize I was
sick hmm I thought I was just jet-lagged
and tired yeah yeah whatever what bug
what in two mornings I woke up shivering
and hot yes
[Music]
I thought it was because the the heater
was on oh I thought it was jet lag too
because remember we came back to same so
by Bahamas in Vietnam yeah we all went
to the danger boys party we all got sick
from that I didn't get sick when we got
look at how even David got sick - I
didn't get David wasn't even there
what's the the SIP party was sick - yeah
but I didn't realize I was luckily KC
sickness was like one day and we hung
out with David the day we came back yeah
and at the end of that jqu so she was
when I started feeling man maybe David
passed around everything [ __ ] David yeah
I had a genius brain with them what day
before that so maybe he was the virus
carrier patient zero but you guys didn't
have swollen lymph nodes you would know
I didn't [ __ ] jellybeans in your
armpit and in it it's painful no I
choked you should because that's where
breath really shows that I really don't
once I got this cancel yeah you really
should look